على بعد اميال من الكريملين تسود حاله من
التاهب القصوى اثر تغيرات في مشهد الحرب
مع اوكرانيا مشاهد تحول فيها المهاجموا
الى مدافع متاهب
موجه من الطائرات المسيره وضعت روسيا في
حاله تاهب قصوى بعد ان وصل بعضها تخوم
العاصمه موسكو امر دفع اعلى السلطات
لتشييد الرقبه على الحدود ومراقبه الحركه
الجويه
وفقا لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه فان القوات
الاوكرانيه حاولت مهاجمه مواقع للبنيه
التحتيه المدنيه في عدد من المناطق الهجوم
استهدف اربع مناطق على الاقل كان ابرزها
اقليم كرسنادار على الجانب الاخر من بحر
ازوف في حين نجحت مسيره بالوصول الى محطه
غاز تابعه لشركه
الواقعه على بعد نحو 60 ميلا جنوب شرق
موسكو امر يعتبر سابقه في الحرب التي بدات
عامها الثاني الاستهداف اجبر موسكو على
رفع مستوى مراقبه الحدود واغلاق المجال
الجوي لمطار سامباروسبورغ مؤقتا وابعاد
الرحلات الجويه وتاخير اخرى الكريم اتهم
كييف بالوقوف وراء الهجوم لترد الاخيره
بالنفي على لسان ميخائيل
مستشار رئيس مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني
اوكرانيا لا تضرب اراضي روسيا الاتحاديه
اوكرانيا تخوض حربا دفاعيه بهدف نزع
احتلال كل اراضيها
في نهايه فبراير العام الفائت اتهمت موسكو
كييف باستهداف بيلجوراد وكورسك وبريان
المتخمه للحدود واليوم تتجدد المشاهد
والاتهامات نفسها لكنها اكثر عمقا وقربا
من تخوم الكرملين